the Halloween season is upon us and that
means a whole slew of horror films will
be hitting theaters I trust you've
already seen Blair Witch and don't
breathe so let's see what other horror
films are worth checking out this
October number five in the mood for a
good slasher film featuring a deranged
serial killer taking victims one by one
then the windmill is probably up your
alley a group of tourists in the
Netherlands wakes up an evil being and
it starts killing everyone who knew
Holland could be so scary the windmill
has a limited release in America on
October 28 number 4 if you're looking
for more of a popcorn horror flick Ouija
origin of evil is for you this time the
film focuses on a seance scam artists
and her two daughters one of the
daughters reaches the other side through
the Ouija board and becomes possessed be
prepared for a ton of jump scares and
what looks like a really fun silly
horror flick Ouija origin of evil opens
on october twenty first number three
ring the 2002 remake of the japanese
film ringu took the country by storm
it's been 14 years since the American
adaptation and now Samara is back the
reboot takes place in our digital age
we're streaming video is right at our
fingertips we'll get to see how many
people this vengeful ghosts will target
in rings hidden theaters on October 28
just make sure to skip the trailer
because it seems to give everything away
number two Rob Zombie is back with a new
horror film that's most likely as
terrifying and disturbing as his last
131 is the story of five carnival
workers who are kidnapped and forced to
play a deadly game of survival if they
can make it for a full 12 hours they'll
be free the trailer shows off some dark
and disturbing moments and if you hate
clowns you may want to skip out on this
one 31 comes to theaters on october
twenty first number one finally the
horror feel you have to check out this
october comes from iranian-born director
baba khan vari during the iran-iraq war
a missile hits a woman's apartment
building but fails to detonate she
believes its curse with the jinn who
wants to possess her daughter the
trailer for the upcoming film looks
terrifying and has a real sinister tone
to it under the shadow opens on october
seven
there you have it for more terrifying
moments in movies television and video
games keep it tuned to gamespot universe